hello everyone and welcome to game
number five from the 1960 World
Championship match between Michael pal
and Mikhail Botvinnik so tal won the
first game the next three games were
drawn and this is Game five I don't know
if you remember tall said that the worst
thing about playing the 1959 candidates
was that he had to play the same
opponent over and over so four games
against every opponent and that that was
extremely tiring you have to keep
preparing for the same opponent over and
over and that was four games here he
will face Mika Botvinnik
over and over and over so this is even
more tiring but he does have to prepare
and yeah I mean it's what he signed up
for
so his again he has the white pieces in
this game and what does he do he knows
that the bottom unit will again go for
the caro-kann as the target tried that
psychological trick and move five in
Game three that G characters on f3 but
as that didn't work there's kind of no
point in repeating that again
so Todd's idea was maybe both winning
but when he probably isn't expecting me
to use something Smith's lob already
used against him in their World Chess
Championship match as those variations
are kind of prohibited because both
winning probably thoroughly analyzed
them and there's no point in repeating
Smith slows moves but Tao found once
again that's maystow played against
Botvinnik where he thought that he could
gain an advantage and move the game from
positional waters and maybe into
combination of water waters so let's see
this game and before we start the game
let's marvel at this photo of towel and
watch Phoenix one more time I will try
to prepare some other photos for Game
six and beyond but for now we have this
one so that being said let's see the
game tall has the white pieces and again
he opens with E for Botvinnik goes for
the caro-kann we had d4 d5 Knight to c3
and now D captures on e4 Knight captures
on e4 and now Bishop to f5 tall goes 4/9
to g3 attacking the bishop on f5 and
kicking it back although during the game
fell did consider this Bishop to d3 move
you know I'm playing the World
Championship so why not sacrifice a pawn
immediately
with the idea that if Queen captures
Knight to f3 Queen goes back and now
Queen to e2 and the white would
definitely get a lot of development for
the price of one pawn but it's a maybe a
too risky thing to try out in a World
Chess Championship match but still said
if this idea doesn't work against the
caro-kann maybe he will have to resort
to ideas like that so Knight to g3
attacking the bishop bishop to g6 and
this is a position from one of Smith's
office games against both winning horse
missile continued with h4 and Todd
didn't want to repeat that so he
prepared another move he prepared Knight
to e2 and now Todd's idea is pretty
clear he wants to go tonight at 14 wants
to go Bishop to c4 and Botvinnik was not
prepared for this as tall says but it's
to both but make some 20 minutes to
figure out his next move and he played a
6 so ok
tall continuous with h4 the threat is of
course h5 so each sense by both tunic
and we have Knight to f4 now
Bishop to h6 not allowing Todd to
exchange this night for both eunuchs
LightSquared bishop and now it all goes
for Bishop to c4
instead of Bishop to c4 c3 is a more
solid move as tal says it himself as
after Bishop to c4 white always has to
it has to worry about this opponent's e2
weakness as the bishop and h7 is buying
it and also the d4 pawn is relatively
weak after he plays c3 then all of those
weaknesses are gone but okay Knight to
f6 and here we have Queen to e2 and here
also spent some time considering the
idea of castling cancelling he thought
this was the best move after castling
and black develops with Bishop to d6 now
tal's idea was to capture 96 simply to
keep the king in the center of the board
after F captures Bishop captures but he
couldn't find any deadly ideas during
the game later he says that in his home
analysis he found some improvements to
this bhakta Botvinnik probably already
checked this sacrifice as well so there
if he didn't play it now in game 5
there's no point like playing it in game
7 because both eunuch will be ready for
it
so after Knight f6 Queen 2
do now both eunuch place Bishop to d6
and here towel place Bishop to e3 one
interesting idea would definitely be
Bishop captures on e6 if F captures on
e6 then white would definitely have the
advantage but the problem is black and
clear simply Castle and now White has
huge problems the king the Queen and the
bishop are all occupying D file and rook
to e8 is coming so this would actually
be a pretty pretty big blunder by table
so after Bishop to d6 he developed the
Bishop to e3 and now Knight B to d7 it's
a probably the best move that really
favors favors Black's positional style
but we can also try to win a pawn here
with Bishop captures on f4 and after
Bishop captures Queen captures but then
Cal has Bishop to e5 and targets the
bishop pair and what eunuch would be a
pawn up but it's a very unclear position
and the botanique isn't interested in an
adventure like this so after Bishop to
e3 about Phoenix simply continues to
develop 9b d7 and we have Knight G to h5
kind of offering to exchange this pair
of Knights attacking the g7 porn and
Botvinnik has to deal with this bot
eunuch plays Knight captures we have
Knight captures and here tau is kind of
inviting both unique to Castle and if
botanique indeed decided to castle here
then dalla could start pushing his king
set points and it would definitely be a
very sharp position but botanique here
plays rook to g8 and it's very
interesting go see you later in the game
that this rook to g8 move will annoy ty
at all very much as he says between
explain it as a defensive move but later
it will become an attacking move so Todd
pushes g4 we have Queen to c7 and now g5
and here you have to do something if H
captors and g5 Bishop captures the king
stays in the center that's good for
white at all definitely would enjoy
capturing an h6 also winning a pawn so
what when he has to do something and he
plays it Bishop to g6 and this is a very
interesting idea that prevents a white
foam from doing either of those things
because now if H capture
if Yugi captures on h6 botnik defense
this would attack the Queen to a5 check
and now Thal simply loses a piece
because the bishop and the Queen are
attacking the knight so after Bishop to
g4 Bishop to g6 power played queenside
castle and here
botany castle as well here top late
night the g3 here tall is preparing h5
he wants to push h5 and after the bishop
moves pushing g6 and then the bishop
will eliminate d6 pawn after F capture
Sanji's after F captors and g6 and there
are a couple of ways black could take
care of this for example black could try
Bishop captures on g3 but after F
characters and Queen captures now pocket
simply capture on h6 pawn captures pawn
captures and Bishop captures black
didn't really win anything here the
material is equal and tall is now at all
now as the bishop pair so this wouldn't
really be a good idea for black
so instead botanique played H captures
on g5 not allowing thought to put the
points Bishop captures on g5 attacking
the rook and now we have been shifted to
a four check forcing towel to exchange
and simplify the position Bishop
captures Queen captures with check and
now Queen to e3 tall definitely doesn't
mind exchange in Queens on e3 as this
would strengthen his Center but here
about to make plays a move that really
annoyed Tao botanique played Queen to h6
and now as stark can't really avoid the
trade of Queens you will have to capture
an h6 at some point and then after
botanique recaptures G captures on h6
then this rock to g8 that was played as
a defensive move now becomes an
attacking move as the rook gains an open
G file so Bishop to d3
now botanique simplifies even further
Bishop captures rook captures and now
Knight to b6 preparing Knight to d5 to
attack the Queen maybe even c4 so it all
gets rid of the Queen Queen captures G
captures on h6 and now rook to f3
attacking the f7 pawn but also if the f7
pawn is defended the threatening rook to
f6 to go for th six point
so botanique stuffs both ideas in place
f5 and now rook to e1 what rock tree one
tall is attacking the e6 pawn and he
offers a simplification if botany
decides to capture the d4 point but he's
also setting a very deadly trap if
Botvinnik may be decided to defend this
pawn with the G would Rock the g6 then
comes the h5 and after the rook moves
Knight to e4 attacking the rook you can
capture the night as you lose the roof
so after the rook moves now comes Knight
to c5 with the threat of Knight captures
on e6 Botvinnik of course didn't fall
for this he played rook to d6 the defend
the upon that way and now topped with c3
solidifying his d4 pawn rook to g4 now
going after the h4 pawn and here tall
played Knight to e2 with the idea okay
between equal capture but I will play
Knight to f4 and then pick up d6 pawn
but Botvinnik stops this immediately
with knife to d5 now the knight can no
longer come to a4 and here tal realized
that again as much as he tries his
position is again very passive he wanted
to look each one he has to defend the
pawn but now comes rug d8 as the rap
wasn't really active on d6 Rock to g3
offering a trade of rooks the Botany
accepts rook captures pawn captures and
now rock the g8 pressuring that as that
g3 pawn is White's weakest point in the
game so King to d2 rook to g4 we have
King t1 and now rook to d7
and here it was miss love suggestion
after the game that maybe although
bringing your King into the game during
the endgame is the the correct way to go
maybe rook to e4 fold by Knight f6 to g4
would give black a better position but
okay that's something that was you know
found after the game so king 37 by
botany
king to have to and now rook to e4 rook
to e1
King goes deeper into the position King
D 6 now night to see one tal wants to
force
whoops as his rope is doing nothing and
botanics rope is pretty active so rookie
actress Kim captures and now c5 topless
King eto we have see characters angry
for seek after some before and now
Knight to f6 and now the material is
equal but but Tull has that isolated d4
pawn so it's it's it's questionable if
botany can make something out of it came
to d3 Knight comes to h5 attacking the
g3 pawn Knight to e2 defending the g3
pawn we have E 5 a 4 and now Knight back
to f6 pawn capture screen captures and B
4 and it was in this position that both
players agreed to a draw so pretty
pretty interesting game once again tall
tries to do something against the
caro-kann and he fails so this is game 5
I do hope you enjoyed it
one thing they agreed to a draw here not
because they didn't want to play this
because they played out the entire game
in their heads and this is the game this
is the variation both of them agreed to
do after the game so this is how the
game would continue Knight h5 b 5f for
pawn captures Knight captures Knight
capture screen captures and now the
black King will go for the H pawn the
White King will go for the Queen side
points and in the end you'll see a very
nice a very nice position I think before
we have King captures a six now H B
captures B captures now King g3
preparing to push a th pawn king c6h5
King c6h4 king b7 h3 not King captures
h2 King to b8 and now a black promotes
the Queen first but now we have a 7 and
as you all know or maybe some of you
don't know this is a drawn position
because you have a queen against the
king and the pawn and the pawn is on the
a file it is on the seventh rank and on
the a file and maybe you'd know this
maybe we don't but if it's a queen
against the king and a pawn and upon is
on the a file the C file the F file or
the H file then the game is drawn on the
other hand if this pawn is on on the B
file on the D file on the e-file or on
the G file then a
we can win this game against the king
and the pawn but this was a drawn
position and this is the only position
they could reach so they agreed to a
draw
so yeah that's game number five like I
said I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Li mo more o Muhammad
could see if Rodney Barnes are no Louie
and Thomas you Andre for a contribution
to my channel think a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon which
gained six from the Talbot Vinick series
thank you and I will see you soon